test hey there we go
there we go
sorry
hello hello i am i'm like a little too
close
backing on up
can we hear me now rocket did not break
the rocket has broken mics before rocket
has broken mike's yes um
she did not break this one still muted
fixed okay cool sounds like it sounds
like it's good there it is thanks mr
anderson ah ombu you want to hear my
voice thank you yeah no roy uh she's
she's big she's a big kitty i wonder if
i go out of frame can you see her better
she's my little fat cat what's funny is
um
when i got her like as a baby i rescued
her um
and she was fat as like a little tiny
baby she had this stomach it was so
funny it was so cute
and as
time got
you know as time went on because she's
she's like 12 years old she's
she's old but she doesn't act like it um
i
i thought she would lose weight and i've
put her on diets and i've taken her to
the vet and i've given her like diet cat
food healthy cat all this stuff put her
on set schedule she's just always fat
she's just one of those fat cats um
so we've accepted or i've accepted that
my my little girl is just a little fat
kitty
all right so let's see i'm going to pull
up
miss but i'm tired tonight guys normally
i'm like all right
excuse me i'm
i'm tired i'm gonna drink some g fuel
if you all drink g-fil use code cosmic
it'll give you a discount
we're episode four time okay yeah we're
episode 14 i was gonna say episode three
is out but we're episode four all right
let's make sure everything's going
schwimmingly
and
yep yep
yep yep
[Music]
how's it going
she's a very lovable cat can i move out
and see her again look how fat she is
she's pretty fine what's up jeff
can't wait to watch thor oh man
thanks for the super chat
i'm i'm curious to hear what everyone
one thinks of the word yeah enchantrex
we're we're close it's been moving kind
of slow but we're close
i'm curious to see what everybody thinks
of thor cause
you know what's interesting is i thor
ragnarok is one of my favorite mcu films
it's like number three
and
i'm i've heard like
quite a few people actually like
mentioning like comments and stuff that
like they don't like thor ragnarok i'm
like oh that's interesting because it's
like my favorite
mcu movie
with the exception of in-game and uh
infinity war
so
it's kind of funny to hear that i think
people who liked ragnarok are really
really gonna love thor love and thunder
um because i think it takes
what thor ragnarok did and and it goes
even further
and it's pretty it's pretty cool it has
some
uh
it has some really really amazing parts
to it i'm not gonna spoil anything
obviously i can't uh disney and marvel
put a uh what's called an embargo
i mean you can't talk about it until a
certain date i even had to take like i
did a really long reaction like a 12
minute long reaction i even had to uh
oops i mean i'd take that down because
they were like yeah it's a little too
long it's a little too much you didn't
really say anything but it's still uh
you know it's a little too much so they
asked me to take that down no big deal
i get it up tire sorry
so uh
i
no spoilers here um
and i j but i just i really
i really really really
love the movie a lot um it was really
really funny
but it had some really good serious
moments
so yeah i i what i would say for thor 11
thunder is to
accept the movie for what it is
and
because i think a lot of times now we go
into you know mcu movies and we're like
oh the connections and all of this stuff
and you know i do that that's what i do
here for a living on my youtube channel
right that's what i do so
uh
just go into thor love and thunder
ready to watch the next door movie and
you're gonna have a blast and you're
gonna love it and it's gonna be an
amazing time
uh so yeah
dubbing stir um
i take it you watch my video
there is uh some reports going around
from some people
uh who have decent track records saying
that the inhumans could possibly be on
the moon
adeline they didn't say that but i'm
assuming adelon's there and not in the
himalayas right now
so
yeah
i
i hope so i think it would just make
sense
ryan shaw what would you bring
to pla thor eleven thunder on
on your all-time mcu list that's hard
cause i gotta see it again it's really
hard for me to say after i've only seen
it once um
but it's up there it's it's it's
definitely like top seven
i have to see it again to determine like
where exactly it was because like
like chang cheese is really high for me
strong cheese probably fourth for me um
the first avengers film is always just
gonna have a huge place in my heart also
that was like
that was
that was the like the first and last
avengers movie that i got to watch with
my dad before he passed away and he's
the reason i love all the stuff so it's
really really cool it holds a deep place
in my heart um and guardians of the
galaxy same thing that was the last
marvel movie i watched my dad and i love
the guardians so that holds a deep place
in my heart too so i have to watch it
again i have to watch it again um
to kind of tell where i rank it but i
think like top seven which is pretty
dang good i think like you know
i can't say you know i couldn't say that
about eternals i couldn't say that about
black widow
uh
i really liked multiverse of madness i
don't know if i could say it's top seven
for me though
um
shang chi definitely is top top five i
think uh
so i think it's a
i think it's a big deal that i i'm
putting in like a top seven
uh hey jeff likes k-pop what's up how's
it going oh yeah that's a long time jeff
did you know that i i do a k-pop channel
now
uh
mr anderson if you want to put that in
the chat for anybody who wants to follow
my kpop channel i sing on it which a lot
of people i guess are very surprised
that i can sing but i grew up
singing and playing in bands like my
whole life
uh did i miss any super chats i just
want to check real quick i don't want to
miss any uh
uh super chats
[Music]
i think i gotta oh jaden rocks that's a
good question what mcu movies do you
need to see before watching thor love
and thunder uh i i'm assuming everybody
has seen avengers in game
that's a must um and i would say
ragnarok it obviously would help if you
watched
thor one and thor two
but i think like if they're like
necessities that you have to watch uh
they they actually do a really good job
at like recapping uh
it it's it's pretty good so i would say
ragnarok and in game are like the must
must must if i had to throw one more in
there guardians
uh well if you watch in-game you kind of
like get the whole guardians feel as
well so like
you don't really need to watch guardians
of the galaxy they do a good job they do
a good job so just make sure you watch
ragnarok and in game and uh you'll be
pretty good
uh
how fast do you go sif how fast do you
think miss marvel is gonna go dark now
this episode
uh
this or this episode next i would like
to say this episode
um
thank you ali appreciate that
i will keep doing the videos uh nanda do
i think marvel is spoiling all the thor
for no actually um
i will just
i won't say much hey what's up ben
pulliam how's it going buddy buddy um
i i'm not gonna say anything that would
spoil the movie but i think they did an
excellent job
at kind of actually keeping the plot a
secret
that's all i'll say
i was pleasantly surprised
hey daniel likes k-pop too then you put
the dance covers dude
i uh my ankles would break i i do know a
lot of dances um
i i do but to sit there and record them
and get it all perfect and and
everything like that might literally
kill me
[Laughter]
i would love to uh i don't know if some
of y'all know but i'm like kind of
partially disabled it's kind of hard for
me to walk
for long periods of time so dancing uh
it takes a lot out of me
i can only like run
or like walk and stand and run and all
that for about two hours tops before my
legs just completely give up
thank you very much love back to india
favorite mcu female superhero uh
it's gotta be the scarlet witch right
yeah it's got to be the scarlet witch i
think it's scarlet witch
uh yeah i do watch anime i have had to
watch so much stuff recently
um that i unfortunately haven't had that
much time to watch anime recently but uh
yeah i do i do actually grew up when i
was like i think like
i think it was like 10 when it first i
was like i was like 9 or ten when uh
dragon ball and dragon ball z started
and like were airing like live and oh
man time of my life
and i i guess i don't know if that's
considered anime now but you know back
then back then it was um
and
yeah that got me into it and then i went
to naruto and uh like attack on titan
and stuff so
yeah
yeah
yeah i i love the scarlet witch and uh
elizabeth olsen
if you're if you stumble upon this
elizabeth olsen i think you're fantastic
and if you want to go on a date i would
love to take you on a date and if you
want to marry me i would love to marry
you
if you're just so happy to be watching
uh
no way homer end game oh that's so hard
legend stud
in game just because of
the spectacle of it all does that make
sense
well that's not fair because it's the
spectacle of no way home is really
big too i
maybe spider-man knew him oh gosh it's
so hard it's so hard oh man uh
it's so it's it's really hard uh
i tie them they're tied they're tied
uh
wait is elizabeth olsen married i didn't
know that
my apologies i didn't know she was
married i wouldn't have said all that
stuff
is it i didn't i didn't i didn't know
she was married but thank you for
clarifying that i retract it no no
offense to your husband
or what if she she married to a man or a
woman i don't know but no offense to
your spouse i didn't know you were
married sorry happy for you wish you a
lifetime of of happiness
now i have to like now she's still my
crush but now i have to think like who's
single you know like in the mcu that i
could you know
oh she's engaged yeah best of luck to
them
best of luck to them
wait rob arnett
is that who i think it is
i was thinking of somebody else
i'm doing it right now who yeah who is
liz
beth olsen married to
oh no that's not how i thought it was
i was taking a will or not
i actually would really like that
this is a good-looking dude just good
luck dude all right all right
yeah i see i see here yeah okay
fine i wish you both happiness and
success and a good marriage
wait since 2018 holy crap she's been
married for a while
actually guys the episode is going to
release in like a minute so i'm gonna
get the stopwatch ready
that's it i didn't know she was married
and i'm like i keep up with all this
stuff too so that's kind of interesting
that one slipped by me maybe i like knew
it but i like
like didn't want to accept it so i like
just kind of like was like
all right what are we doing tonight
uh i can't feel you over here i can hear
you over here that song is stuck in my
head
mama what you gonna do now charlie poof
freaking
jk jungkook
they got me with their catchy songs
move tab to new window and we're going
to move this over here we're going to
cover my face
but keep the chat open because we got to
see the chat
uh i think it's out now
i think it's out i think it's out i
think it's out i think it's out
yep it's out are we ready
are we ready we are going to start this
mr anderson in five
a four
three
[Music]
two
one let's go
oh no yeah mr anderson's working on his
phone
can you hot spot it mr anderson oh i
didn't start the timer
yeah close enough
oh i have to put the timer up
whoops
glenda
is everything
good
i was actually surprised that comrade
was uh like ended up being like good
let's do it let's do it let's do it
let's do it
i can fill you with a good new uv
oh yeah
nakia found out and we never like uh
i never saw how that went 59 seconds
oh yeah that's how it ended just gotta
come to karachi
i wonder what kind of cool music they
have for us today
who i think will play doctor doom man
i'm really not sure about that one
i could give you like wolverine and all
that stuff but dr doom i don't know
i i thought
keanu reeves would do a good job but i'd
like to see him play like ghost riders
and
oh
this is good music i'm feeling it i'm
vibing
yo i actually like that that's fire
can somebody tell me what instrument
that's being played on
i need the soundtrack to this
wait who's that
wait who are these people
that was her mom
jen pb engine what's up
oh interesting
temporary truce
i'm so sorry please answer me alex uh oh
gosh she's sent her like a million texts
why is everybody getting up
karachi
i really hope john quincency is going to
be the 616 mr fantastic if he's not that
would be a travesty because he is
literally perfect
not her cousins
cut
hey
there she is
noise
oh i was gonna say it seemed like there
was like a little bad blood there but
they seem alright
please don't spam guys if you if you
spam you're gonna get timed out
if you keep spamming you'll get banned
you say the city of lights i didn't
catch that
just win hey uh you know i gotta see it
again and thank you for that super chat
it's hard to say because i really need
to see it again but like an eight
like an eight out of ten maybe a nine
it's pretty up there i really really
loved it
guys i'm not gonna answer any spoilers
about thor love and thunder sorry
hey it's amman how's it going thank you
appreciate that
wow that's a big house
that's a big house
dang
yeah it's real
i mean yeah we want the chat to be good
for everybody
right
gosh that's a big house
that's cool amanda's culture i'm glad
you could uh
glad you could relate to that
guys i'm not answering any spoilers
about thor 11 thunder sorry
oh my gosh there's gonna have to be so
many easter eggs and all these newspaper
articles that they have
that's true man does culture money is
different overseas
i'm trying to look for easter eggs
oh
ah is it her great-grandmother
oh
[Music]
okay okay okay okay
let's get into it let's get into it
oh here we go we're getting into it
we're getting into it
no problem maverick
okay okay
genetics okay okay okay okay okay
okay
it is the same train sweet okay okay
okay
dude that's what i'm saying mando's
culture in humans man
figure
i like that you learn to find beauty in
the pieces
uh guys i can't share my screen because
disney blocks it it's literally just a
black screen when i share it
unfortunately i used to share it until
disney started blocking it
yeah and it definitely copyright um i've
definitely gotten like in in trouble
before because of it but you know
it's sauna's your grandmother i'm
assuming
that
all right give me the red dagger give me
red dagger let's go let's go let's go
please don't be weird we're here to
visit
uh guys we're watching it right now
that's what the timer on the screen is
for
controversial
hmm
that's funny
yeah the dad didn't go
oh she needs to talk to them
oh she definitely needs to talk to them
uh tonta i was most hyped for thor love
and thunder and i really loved it um
now i think i'm most excited for
guardians 3.
i'm not sure if i've ever had any
pakistani food
maybe like once but i don't remember
like
abcd's instagram
hello a lock what's going on what's up
marvel's geek what's up
those were the worst directions in the
history of direction giving
i stopped moving the screen so fast i'm
trying to search for easter eggs
i thought
maybe she'd see something in
the like the picture
kamala i'm not sure just the mask is
really hiding who you are
but then again
people can't tell clark kent is superman
because of glasses so who am i to say
and wonder woman just walks around with
her baby bare face oh red dagger red
dagger
there he is
all right all right i'm in it
oh
i like it
huh
nice nice nice
oh
that did straight up almost killed her
dude if that dagger would have hit her
in the face
that's pretty good
all right
how do you know aisha
terminator
i'm so happy we finally saw red dagger
for a while i thought it was going to be
comrade but i was like no because he's
in pakistan and whatever i'm glad we got
it finally
oh thank you dustin i just saw that i
really appreciate that
try i try to make some good videos i've
been trying to get uh
try to try to always improve so that
really means a lot to me thank you uh
tanza thank you as well
oh thank you i'm glad you found the
channel recently i hope you continue to
enjoy it
all right so who is red dagger with
marcus ninja turtles and donkey kong in
the mcu cannon confirmed
welcome to the red daggers and tristine
yo
yo that's fire
yo that's so cool
i need a secret layer
i've got a basement maybe i'll just like
close it off and make a secret entrance
to the basement so no one knows about i
need a layer
uh no tome holland i i have not watched
the boys i've watched the first couple
of episodes and uh
kind of wasn't for me
what up dude
yeah the mask really hit who you were
hey that's the famous bollywood actor
right
um
they're in chinese
got em
red dagger
their scarfs are red mass gamer
uh no red dagger doesn't really have any
power
did mention the himalayan mountains
dude inhumans are you gonna say it
freaking say oh my gosh come on dude are
they really about to like do in humans
right now
all right things get intense things are
getting intense
yo
that's tight
oh i thought it was terrigan missed at
first holy crap
hmm
interesting
okay come on someone say the word in
humans
you think you can just trust them kamala
you thought you could trust the
clandestines
hello simon abrams
i didn't see what that said and i'm
gonna transfer i'm gonna go back just a
little bit to see what that said
super max prison department oh
they got comrade
oh dang who we're gonna see in here that
breaks well i guess
oh yeah they caught all of them
nice
hey thanks joshua i really appreciate
that
i love doing
them even though i am tired tonight
these do seem like shield weapons don't
they
uh thanos it's
it's
not spoiler-free
i react to it you know
rude
yo
that sucks
it's also like holy crap your mom
are those kites
those are kites cool
you
that's pretty cool
oh look at oh the kites formed uh
be young that's funny
sloth baby
okay okay okay
i'm curious as to what this food is
she gonna like throw up and die because
it's so spicy
why would you eat that much oh my gosh
if you don't know it's spicy why would
you eat that much
nice
the house is big and i definitely gonna
need the soundtrack to this
bro why are you nagging your mom so much
don't you feel stupid now
oof looks like it
hurts but good daughter good daughter
you were nagging but now you're a good
daughter
moving to america
i knew it i knew it
she laughed
oh
yeah i do have one cat
rock
rocket yes named after rocket raccoon
but she's a girl
hello movie world
thank you appreciate that
i'm expecting like some stuff to go down
and i was expecting inhumans
we did get to see red dagger i like him
we need more
that was good fight scene
huh
i think you should tell your mother
what's happening
i really want you to tell your mother
what's happening dang it
alright tanza have a good one
oh here we go here we go here we go here
we go here we go what is happening
i do read marvel comics bro
oh is is that her scarf is it gonna be
no
oh nice i like it
no snap
yo
duke and fight
oh
all right that's pretty good i love
hand-to-hand combat
yo
i really like how calm he is when he
fights
run dude
that was pretty cool it kind of freaked
me out for a minute i was like why is
that guy
shoving his own face
on his uh
why is the guy shoved in his own face
but the other guy shoved him against it
what's that guy holding kind of weapon
is that
oh it's like a big
rude
dude slam on the brakes
oh no that was some that was something
else
rude
you're gonna have to use your powers
nice
oh
well i'm glad she like
harnessed her powers and was able to
the bug in my room
a good old marvel chase scene
oh snap
wait what
it's only got the front wheel
i feel like they're gonna know you split
up
but maybe not
uh yeah i think we are gonna join chris
after to talk about it
that's funny
oh that sucks that's rude
are they all split up they are all split
up
oh
keep driving what keep driving
i want to know what this weapon this guy
has is like golden
it's like a round hammer
yo okay that was cool that was really
cool
oh
oh no
well
i feel like you could definitely survive
that
huh the except the subtitles blades
unsheathed
nice
what is that thing oh there you go
okay kamala
did she cut him
nice
oh the spinning jump kick
yo
what
get him red dagger
oh oh oh oh oh oh
all right all right all right all right
what's going on
i feel like we gotta we kind of
kind of
gotta start getting some answers here
all right we need some answers
we need some answers
the train has to crouch here
oh is that them
no listen
well this is definitely they just said
that's the last train this is partition
happening
dang look at that
i'm thinking so jen i'm thinking she'll
see oh that's it
i don't like that ending
they're opposed to credit
no post credit
no post credit
okay
well that was something
i'm tired
how do we feel about this episode
i don't know how i feel about this
episode i i did hate that ending
like
yeah lily's fandom i i kind of feel the
same like
why why why
do
you keep doing this to us like
huh
well
uh
yeah two episodes left and
i'm getting worried be
cause i feel like we don't have enough
yet and we only have two episodes left
like there were some parts that i really
liked in this episode um
definitely some really cool parts i
liked in this episode
but
[Music]
i feel like we didn't get much out of
the episode
that it was kind of just leading us to
the like the next
episode and i'm like
i don't see a clear like
i don't see the direction it's going
uh
i don't see the direction it's going
it's because this is supposed to build
up to the marbles um
and so i'm i'm thinking that the post
credit for
the
finale is going to be captain marvel
showing up
because
yeah
yeah sue exactly like yeah i i see i see
now i'm seeing uh
i've seen a lot of people saying the
same thing like not seeing where the
show is going and i'm not really either
um
yeah i'm not really seeing too much of
where the story's going um
i liked red dagger i like the fight
scenes i think we got the most uh
i think we got the most from kamal's
powers this episode which is pretty cool
but
i'm trying to just think like
there's a lot of filler stuff in this
episode i feel like they like this
episode could have
like there's a lot of things you could
cut out of this episode and have
replaced with like i think more
important things i don't know i'm not a
writer
right i just feel like there's so much
they need to do
in episode five and six now
you know
uh
yeah let me text chris
and see if he's getting on
is he still alive
he's still alive
let me text the christopher's
um
hey what's up malek what's going on man
i haven't seen you in a bit
i know mass gamer i still think there is
any human connection
um i mean they keep talking about her
dna and the gin and things like that
uh
this this is just
i think everyone's kind of confused i
and i can like you know there are
several
hype
hello
you get some rest
everybody seems to be pretty confused
yeah just like where where the show's
going
that i don't think
we even have an answer to necessarily
but what's up jillian
we were just discussing the fourth
episode conundrum
yeah that's a thing for sure it's
absolutely a thing yeah i think
that yeah go ahead no i just i think
they have so much to do in episode five
and six now
yeah absolutely was this six episodes
yeah
yeah um fair point derek they did talk
about the himalayan himalayan mountains
which is originally where adalan the
city of the inhumans is
yes
so
there was a lot of information
definitely gonna be a fun breakdown
video yeah um
but
overall i don't think it has really gone
in a direction we don't we weren't
expecting like what did we think was
gonna happen when she got there we were
gonna get all this information that
doesn't really have any clarity because
that's the fourth episode conundrum
they're like
kind of pushing all the stuff they've
been teasing us for the first half of
the series now the fourth episode's in
charge of kind of gluing it together and
setting up the expectation for five and
six so a few people like eh it wasn't as
good as the rest like yeah it's kind of
not that's that's the point of the
fourth episode it's like why
they shouldn't have like this unspoken
rule if that's the deal for episodes for
you know maybe not but that's the
formula that they've gone with so far so
like you can kind of use that yeah it's
dumb um
i don't feel like the story progressed
any
this episode did it like let's think
about it like yeah might i mean we
didn't get any answers no no we got the
red daggers and red dagger um
not much of anything right but it's just
kind of like
they're just responsible for like
protecting pakistan at night right
that's like what red dagger does in
comics but it's like
okay they kind of told us that like oh
it's this other realm yeah we knew that
we didn't know it was part of earth
it's like we learned a little bit but
it's like
we should have like halfway into this
episode she should have went through the
vision of the train station and they
should have showed us everything
yeah
yeah though the next two episodes have a
lot of work
or they're just gonna leave us on yet
another massive well i think i think i
don't think in the i don't think in the
sixth episode in the finale they're
gonna like
yawn hold on
yeah me too that's why i was like not
too too long i gotta go sleep i don't
think we're going to get captain marvel
showing up in the sixth episode i think
it's going to you know the post credit
scene no i think it's like the post
credit of the six episodes yeah i
probably would make more sense though
they would want to probably keep this
about her that's what they always do
i would like some answers about the ten
rings which again
probably not gonna get red swagger
that's funny
like the whole
teasing of the ten rings is very
intriguing to me and it could be
potentially you know the biggest
connection in phase four so far
but then they've gone and they're gonna
ignore it and it's just gonna exist in
the background until they're ready to
use it
i don't think it's all gonna really
come out
until
like
maybe cigarette invasion maybe the
marvels
i
because like let's think about it like
they are no longer exploring
where the bengal came from
because if you think about it the gin
gave up on the other bengal
forever ago
yeah they just want to
combine their unit right they find their
universes that's all they care about
right i mean they showed us you know the
flashback and whatever that time was you
know 100 years ago whenever it was i
don't remember
but uh
they're like oh there's supposed to be
two one will have to do they gave up a
long time ago right so we're not yeah
right we're no longer
going into the discovery of are these
the nega bands where's the other one
blah blah blah blah where did they get
it from like that's not a part of the
story anymore right so that
the cree connection and all that stuff i
feel like
it it is gone
because what is the like what is the
the finale what is the finale now like
are they really going to introduce like
new because you have to think about what
other marvel disney plush shows have
done
like we've always thought like oh
there's going to be these like big
people introduced and like the final
episodes and stuff like that and it like
never happens right no they stick to
what the show is about so what project
either announced or not announced
do we actually you know and i'm not
actually being impatient i know a lot of
people out there want that connection
you know mcu is fun because it connects
but when you look back to iron man
captain america thor like these movies
their big connection was name drops like
oh they mentioned the city or they
mentioned a character or an activity or
an event that they had to go check out
that looking back we know connected
right and everybody it seems the
majority of fans are getting impatient
because phase four is all over the place
so where do you if you just have to
guess whether it's it's something we
know that's coming or something we don't
know where do you start seeing these
ties being put together because we know
there is a plan i think
i think it's i so
in in secret invasion in the comics it's
the scroll who have infiltrated
everybody i think it's gonna be the cree
and the scroll
um
and i'm starting to think it's it's like
gonna be like a play on the inhumans
because right like uh the cree
experiment
on humans that's how we get the inhumans
in the comics
and the reason the creed do this is
because they want the inhumans to be on
their side and they don't just do humans
they experiment on other races as well
so they can infiltrate you know a bunch
of different other races and stuff like
that so i think it's gonna be a
combination of like the korea people
infiltrating much different places the
scroll have people
infiltrating a bunch of different places
and we are seeing
some pieces
of that everywhere now like the tin
rings cree technology the relics yeah
right you know all these different
relics and stuff like that like is is it
all gonna be brought together
uh for secret invasion and then is like
the really heavy hitter secret wars like
another avengers movie it's gonna i
think that's how they're gonna tie it
together it's it has to be some big
event
um
and secret invasion is gonna be a big
event i'm actually kind of like
concerned it's a tv show like
right you think it should be like a big
movie or something we'll see hopefully
they can avoid any fourth episode
conundrums
yeah i mean here's a good point that
you're going to want to hear from diego
hernandez
he said i'm a little bit confused with
the end but can kamala be the one that
made the trail of stars for nani did we
just see time traveling here
oh maybe
was she the one that actually ended up
making the star trail
it's possible
i mean where they just mentioned all of
these dimensions
um
and they just like yeah this is just one
of them there are millions of dimensions
on earth that line up in a map with
different types like right this is so
much knowledge that they actually did
just drop in one episode that doesn't
have a necessary
or doesn't necessarily have a connection
moving forward so it is very open-ended
loose-ended knowledge about the mcu
that's not a small deal
right
i we were talking about that um
we were talking about maybe kamal is
aisha
or however yeah you know that's
basically almost
kind of the same thing kind of not but
like because we all assume she's the one
who made the trail of stars right
right so it's kind of like the same
thing um
yeah uh
oh that's pretty cool sue yeah you can
watch all this now yeah i mean i i i
think that's probably what is happening
here that'd be a cool little twist to
throw but like
i'm sorry but like what is it like why
who cares
right i mean it's cool but like
where you going
with that right but do you think i mean
as a marvel fan interacting with marvel
fans all the time do you think that
us sitting here questioning okay where
does this connect
what is how where does this you know
become the mcu and not just a show
is that us being impatient or is that
marvel falling off
because it's being translated i think
largely by fans that marvel's falling
off i think but
you interact with marvel with disney
with fans daily where where do you stand
on that
uh you know maybe a little bit of both
uh but here here's really my input
on this
we didn't have disney plus shows before
guys no not even a little bit just three
movies a year
right and not even always three it
wasn't always three sometimes two and
now we have four movies a year and like
and projects
it's exhausting right it's so much the
reason that they have these disney plush
shows is so they can actually introduce
these things on their own
and that's the point and they have to
stay true to that right and kevin feige
said that
and they're gonna come together
in the movies
well what was the big thing the first
ever disney plus
marvel trailer they gave us
the blue background with the disney plus
trailer and the logo and the marvel
studios logo and in the very middle
the universe is expanding
you know this is a much bigger wave than
the first three
you know if if the first phase was a one
foot wave and the second phase with a
three foot wave and in phase three the
end of the saga was like a nice solid
five foot wave like we're looking at
starting
this phase this multiverse saga or
whatever we want to call it with a
straight out ten foot wave
yeah
and you can't see over that you don't
know where we're going you don't know
where we're headed but like we mentioned
there is a plan well kevin feige even
said that there's a plan i'm confident
that there's a plan well kevin feige
came out like a week ago not a year not
even a week ago where he was like look
fans are going to see it soon
yeah
and i think that's because
one sdcc and uh d23 are coming up
and uh
there's some movies coming out right
yeah we're only a few connecting of the
dots away i think from everything just
really making sense and getting really
really excited
i just hope that the fan base can
maintain their
their calm collective mentality while
we're waiting for that well and here
here's a comment right here by tux is it
just me or am i the only one getting mcu
fatigue right now
and i think uh
you know that's definitely not wrong to
ask right tucks i think a lot of people
are in your are feeling
you a lot of people aren't a lot of
people still love it like i personally
still love it and i accept these shows
for what they are i would love huge big
big connections and reveals and stuff
like that but it's kind of like i just
said you have to think back to what
kevin feige said
the whole like
the benefit i should say
of disney plus shows is so they can do
these things on their own they can take
their time to develop a singular
character
right
moon knight
loki and i mean loki had some pretty big
impacts which i think is why it was so
huge
right right like we've done watch
parties for every disney play show so
far lucky was by far the biggest and
like my breakdowns were by far the
biggest because everyone's like this
clearly connects to everything right so
it's definitely more exciting
but that's not like the rule
for the disney plush shows you know what
i mean it's definitely not the right
thing not when your title character is
not only a new character but a
relatively
unknown character same with moon knight
like moon knight was really good and
people enjoyed it but it wasn't as big
of an event no and it was a new
relatively unknown character right it
was about moon night
right so
this is about kamala khan so like
i think for like the new shows where
they introduce like new characters it's
just about them it's telling their story
so they can so like by the time the big
stuff happens
in the movies like you know the
character
so yeah
yeah i'm a big advocate for a trusted
process we've not actually been let down
yet and two manage our own expectations
you know and i'm not saying you have to
love every single marvel project and i'm
not just sitting here fanboying for
marvel i am a massive fan warren is a
massive fan that's why we've started
youtube channels you know and we're
super blessed to be where we are with
them
but
you got to trust the process and you
have to exactly like what warren is
saying right now look at these projects
for what they are like ms marvel was
never meant to be anything other than
miss marvel same with
pretty much every other
project we've gotten on disney plus
yeah that's what they are they're
building projects they're they're
introducing new characters like iron
man's gone captain america is gone
you know a lot of these characters that
we the og characters are gone they have
to build new characters they just have
to
so i do think patience is a is a big
part of what this community is going to
have to develop because i don't think
we're even going to be at like an
avengers movie next year we're not there
yet it's going to be a slow build
yeah i i definitely think we need to
have some patience uh louise barry
thanks for the super chat uh no
definitely not my favorite episode so
far
the first one
uh yeah last episode was pretty good
episode last episode was fun yeah uh
john guerra thanks for that super chat
this is common theme for disney slash
lucasfilm as of late trying to cram
everything in the last two episodes with
too much exposition not enough
clarification yeah i mean that's what i
was i don't know if you were here like i
don't know 10 minutes ago or whatever
that's kind of what i'm saying i was
like i'm kind of worried because there's
a lot to tackle in five and six
uh and you know that was the c you know
you mentioned lucasfilm it kind of was
the same for obi-wan now that paid off
that worked
i loved ob1 oh i can't express so much i
love
obi-wan but here's also a good point
from sue i think as a fan there's
nothing wrong with expecting exciting
high-quality shows and you're right
and
you know i
the the the
i'll say the issue
might not be the right word but i'm
gonna i'm gonna stick to the issue i'm
gonna stick to saying that word the
issue with having so much disney plus
shows is you're probably not gonna like
all of them
right i i i'm curious right i i'm i'm
curious like you know all the indian
people who are here in the chat right
now like are y'all really enjoying this
right the pakistani people like are you
all really enjoying this um because it
has to do you know with your culture and
stuff like that and i'm the type of
person i'm like i kind of find it cool
like seeing this other culture right but
i i like i
i find it cool but like not in like an
mcu sense and like i enjoy what i'm
watching but at the same time it's like
not really
like it's but it's who this marvel is
but at the same time like the story
still needs to be good you can't just
like wow me with cultural stuff you know
what i mean like right i need a good
story to go along with it yes it's
really cool i like seeing and learning
about it um but it's like
i want to know it needs to finish like
it has to have a good ending oh a lot
rides on these next two episodes right i
think arguably other than maybe loki
more than any show we've seen so far for
disney
wait what say that like
i think other than loki
because loki's ending was pretty
important oh for sure but this show is
going to rely on the next two episodes
more than moon night more than one
division
like it is gonna be determined like this
is a bad show this is a good show by
what we see next they've built something
but we just don't know what it is
they're building so whatever it is
they're building has to kind of blow us
out yeah for sure um
and that's kind of a question okay so i
i do feel
like kabbalah is the one who's gonna
make the trail of stars for her
i agree i agree i think she's somehow
stepped in whether it's a limbo world
that's between time the train actually
is between borders and not actually out
of the the partition
yeah whatever it is
yeah louis barry thanks for super chat
yeah i i don't think you're alone
thinking that episode's the worst so far
um
last two minutes were fun and you hope
to get spidey black bolt matt karen
foggy it's a lot of expectations yo
ahsoka tana in the chat i'm indian and
hindu and i'm really relating to it
which surprised me phase four has been
majorly disappointing man this is uh
well first of all thank you for super
chat i'm glad that you are relating to
this um even though if that is
surprising to you
um
i don't like see here's like the thing
like phase four
and it depends on what you like but like
has it been disappointing because like i
hear a lot of people say that and
everyone's entitled to their own opinion
spider-man the way home dr strange but
that's what spider-man at home doctor
strange multiverse madness
i feel like it's better thunder you're
all gonna love it you know right i feel
like it's been pretty good i personally
really like those shows if you don't
like those shows and movies then of
course it's not good for you but like
yeah there were a few like
i i'm very open about this i don't like
what if at all like i just hate it i
hate what if just like i just i was so
bored and and and it was just so useless
to me i was just like i hated
doing breakdowns on it like
like i
it just wasn't for me some people loved
it some people loved it and good for you
i'm glad you loved it because it's not
fun sitting there watching not enjoying
it
um
but
you know
it's not that's the whole point is like
there's so much stuff happening and it's
not
it's not gonna be a hit every time but
you know i kind of agree with you at the
same time like i don't know i kind of i
kind of do expect it all to be a hit
every time
um
because if you think about like there's
only
like in the first three phases there's
only a handful of movies that don't hit
you know what i mean
but hey
marvel you set the bar pretty dang high
yeah
their own tail i guess they put
themselves in this mess let's see if
they can climb out
yeah i'm actually seeing a lot of people
say what if was pretty
uh
a lot of people did like it but i yeah
i don't know i like moments of it a lot
oh yeah they were like the dr
strange supreme episode was
cool i i actually really like that one i
like that one a lot um
uh
and if you enjoyed it awesome i'm never
one to like shame people for what they
liked or tell them you're not wrong
right because you like what you like i
like what i like
and uh i everything else i've actually
enjoyed i can't really think of like i
haven't sat there and disliked anything
i i haven't sit there and disliked
anything besides what if
uh i feel like something that i and i
don't want to speak for everybody but i
just speak for the fan base i suppose i
feel like from my interactions with
people is people aren't enjoying the
lack of connectivity after coming off of
infinity war when everybody was on the
battlefield together and you know we had
this big huge coming event
that now we're back and watching some
little girl in her bedroom and having
high school drama like people don't
really want that anymore but the problem
is we kind of have to be there
so yeah maybe you don't like miss marvel
as much but miss marvel's gonna be
pretty cool five six years from now when
secret wars is happening right you know
the character that well yeah i think we
need to really think about the long
game the long game avengers long game
avengers long game
avengers it finally connects
uh just long game and part two avengers
they finally can avengers and finally
connect but it is true like when we go
to watch
four or five years down the road i don't
know at what point
the next big team-up film against tang
yeah we need everybody midnight suns
show up and you know who moon knight is
right because they did go into these
painstaking fourth episodes with all
these details that maybe you don't care
about now yeah you know that character
you can have a connection to that
character same with miss marvel and some
people like moon knight more than miss
marvel or vice versa or this character
or
and that's all going to come to you as
time goes on but right now we're just
meeting these characters these are the
awkward and almost dare i say boring
introductions to these characters who
several years down the road we're gonna
love when the team up movies happen no
for sure for sure and and i'll just keep
bringing it back to what kevin feige
said that ties into what you said chris
the
the disney plus shows are so they can
focus on the stories of who they are
about
one division focused on the story of one
division loki on loki a bunch of
different loki's moon knight was moon
right falconer soldier they focused on
them right there were no like big huge
introductions with the exception of kang
right
that's right and just in the background
stewing stirring right exactly
so
yeah and louis berry thanks for the
super chat i i hope carol and monica get
connected by the end i think it's gonna
be a post-credits scene
and in the for the finale
or maybe the very last clip it's gonna
just be like captain marvel showing up
it's like what's up kid you gotta come
with me to fight some cree and scroll
you know what i mean you're more
important than you know
yeah
and
maybe it is the fourth episode conundrum
but uh
the the this show has
the opportunity still to finish very
strong
um
if they pull something
they pull something like kind of big uh
you know what i mean because like i feel
like
i don't feel like we've gotten any good
action from the show
it's been like bursts of like two
minutes yeah but you're like we're
coming off of moon night which was just
incredible it's like some of the best
action we've gotten too so it's like
hard it's difficult when these these are
so close to each other and
you just watched thor love and thunder
as well which had some of the coolest
fight scenes thoroughly dinner has some
amazing some of the best fights some of
the best i've seen in a long time but
i mean
still
i haven't got we haven't got much from
it like if you even think about
the second episode
it had that cool montage for like
working out and like training and
there's some cool stuff there most of
the fighting is just kind of punching in
right but
but even when
even when it came down to her like
becoming the superhero like she was
stepping so slowly on those platforms to
save the kid and then it's like oh let
me throw a few you know platforms down
and i i swung with the arm and i missed
it and i'm just kind of like yeah it's
kind of cool but it's like
uh tahin sinha
another member of the chat what up to be
honest every marvel's fourth episode was
d plus mid that's what we were talking
about that's what we were talking about
so like
this was actually i think the most
action that we've got
with the whole car scene and the
fighting
inside the back that was cool
like don't get me wrong there are cool
parts to this
show
i just think it needs to move a little
faster especially after watching this
last
yeah episode fourth episode conundrum
hopefully the five and six can carry
this into a a cool story that will lead
miss marvel into a productive future
with the mcu because i think a lot of
people like the actress i think the
character has a lot of potential oh
she's great iman is fantastic
awesome she's so cool so
i just thought of something kazoo
so you just said that she said couldn't
agree more an amazing action amazing
action scenes from moon knight this show
seems too humble maybe marvel just needs
to order things a little bit better like
it doesn't
like they haven't actually told us where
anything kind of takes place
for the disney plush shows right i mean
this has to be post junction
of course i mean i think so but but the
thing is they haven't really said so
like if you're not saying it doesn't
necessarily matter until later on down
the road and you can say whatever events
happen in whatever order maybe marvel
just kind of needs needed to like maybe
this should have been like one of the
first things we got right
right and like hawkeye one of the first
things but at the same time like
if they didn't come out strong people
aren't sticking around for the better
shows right so it's like
um
so
the red dagger stuff was cool i really
liked it um was it what was his name
walim right
no i can't remember i'm too tired
super cool super cool yeah that part
where he threw the daggers into the wall
and jumped on him and grabbed them and
uh yeah that was really cool there's a
lot of cool her fight with him was kind
of fun although short but it was it was
fun
yeah no and that was the most we saw her
use her powers ever yeah absolutely
without like
being scared to use them she was
confident even the whole time they're
doing that chase look i can't do
anything like you could build a wall and
stop the bus what are you talking about
yeah
i can't do anything like this yes you
can
so katana thanks for that super chat
again best of phase four miss marvel
doctor strange too loki where's was
spider-man no way home wow falcon winter
soldier black widow can't wait for the
force better know him was to nostalgia
fest for me
okay
don't entirely agree but you're entitled
to your opinion uh i do agree with the
other ones though um
yeah
black widow was kind of a mess which is
sad because i didn't want it to be
i just think it was too late it was too
late it really was too late better if it
was on its own it would have been better
if it was actually between infinity war
and yeah
too late it was a relevant story
had some cool moments in it but
regardless it was just here
uh brooks boracus thompson um kind of
confused about your question
um but i i i think kamala is going back
in time and she's going to do the whole
trail of stars thing
or back in dimension something like that
yeah louis berry amanda's stealing the
show hope we get her
and sm
i don't know what that means
i don't know what sm is spiderman
spiderman
a lot of people are expecting spiderman
in this i would not guys like
really really really
almost guarantee you there won't be no
spider-man at this yeah
yeah justice for waleed i think it was
okay yeah um i think mr anderson that's
right it did give us your lena and i
actually do really really love yelena
she's oh it did i just think the movie
as a whole
would have been more successful in its
own time the story would have been more
relevant people would have cared more
yeah uh how do i think mutes are going
to come to mcu uh
it's that's a big question um yeah it
really is i think kevin feige has big
plans
um hopefully this can lead to a little
bit of that i you know that's what i
talked about today i i do think there's
an inhuman connection here i do think
she is an inhuman they may not they
might not
still have an identifier right they
might not hit the nail on the head with
it they might not come out and be like
oh yeah you're what's called an inhuman
right or waiting
yeah yeah yeah um
i think
what i talked about today was if the
inhumans are on the moon or in another
realm
that's nice because that separates them
from the mutants because
you know a lot of people are like well
what's the difference between them it's
like well the terrigen mist has to
activate the inhuman gene blah blah blah
like it's like i think i think uh
i think it's a good thing that if the
inhumans are like
different type of species in a different
realm something like that right it
separates them
and that's how like this could lead into
that by saying like oh there's this like
there's this like alien race that are
like kind of humans but blah blah blah
it's like oh well they're actually
humans
here
that kind of have those powers as well i
personally think doctor strange is still
the key to it how do you see all these
superheroes and not seek them out in
your own world how do you see mr
fantastic and not seek him out in your
own world
right professor x the psychic right how
do you not go where the hell is this guy
in my universe i could have used him to
fight daniel these people defeated
thanos where the hell were they in our
universe
right it's like what the hell i had to
go through time a million times but
big questions there right exactly that's
always to me been like you just can't
ignore that now that it's been shown i
don't care if it's in a different
universe
if i were doctor strange in real life
and i saw all these people i would go
back and be like i have to find these
guys
like is the illuminati a thing in my
universe like and i don't know about it
like did they do it without me what's
going on
so
yeah
well i think i think i need to go to bed
yeah
i'm gonna
i'm gonna
wrap my head around this and do the
breakdown tomorrow
lots of cool reveals that i think one
day will make a lot of sense the problem
is right now they don't hopefully the
next two episodes pay off
um
yeah i have to wrap my head around this
but i
i hope it pays out well not what we were
expecting this episode though
no i i expected the story to progress a
little i actually expected
more to be reviewed like i think in the
middle of this episode they should have
got to the train station and done
whatever they're about to do already but
hey yeah
let's see what they have coming um
and again it
it
leads into the marvels and secret
invasion so something big could happen
i'm not going to expect it at this point
because
there's a lot that
needs to get done in two episodes i'm
not going to expect it but
you know who knows
well and guys keep keep in mind uh
was it
iron man 2
tony stark's phone had an illuminati app
on it
the illuminati probably exists in the
mcu
and maybe they did it without doctor
strange and i think this needs to be
addressed
maybe it will be we've got lots of time
lots of projects lots of shows that we
haven't even thought of yet that are all
coming out yeah lewis berry i i hope so
too thanks for that super chat next two
hit like
um
dave lopez the next episode's gonna have
more because he's gonna come in and he's
gonna say it's morbid time
and and that's going to be the big
reveal i will never watch it
done
okay deleting the channel yeah
so
all right everybody i have to go to bed
me too i'm tired
do suas from me to you
right here on cosmic culture yeah
all right everybody say goodbye to chris
he'll see you and um
thank you mr anderson he was moderating
from his phone
today uh because he was visiting us yeah
visiting his parents and
uh i guess the internet went down or
something like that so did it from his
phone and he did it a lot i watched it
thank you mr anderson
shout out to him uh he has his own
channel for those who are interested go
check it out i'm sure he'll link it down
below um that might be kind of hard for
him to do pretty quickly um uh because
he's on his own like we talked about um
also
head over to chris at cosmic culture and
uh if you're here i i want to say it's
up to me but if not
do not do it go ahead and sub if you
want if not
no worries dude
uh
we're here we're here so if you want to
join us for the ride and support the
channel
super appreciate it
cillian murphy is one more ps good night
say good night to chris everybody
uh louis barry thank you for the
multiple super chats i really appreciate
that i appreciate all the other super
chats as well i appreciate the regular
chats and i appreciate everybody who
just watched because we're all having a
good time together
we're all talking about together coming
up with theories whether it's in your
mind my mind speaking it out loud it's
all a bunch of fun love it
um
i'm going to wrap my head around i have
some ideas in my mind i got to put them
together i don't want to smell out loud
yet because i'm going to sound like you
know stupid
if
they're just completely just off but
i'm so tired
i can't even think straight right now so
i'm probably gonna go to bed now wake up
watch it again
um
probably you know
probably two more times one to just
watched again and another one to kind of
go through it and really like see
what's going on um
i think things are gonna get better oh
thanks bro i appreciate that i think
things are gonna get better
i don't think these disney plush shows
have to be as connected
as we want them to be because i think
the movies are what's going to connect
them so i'm holding out for the big
movies holding up for the big movies
uh thank you everybody talking uh
great stuff about um the live stream
they're super fun i love chatting with
everybody
and just talking about all this stuff so
it's dream come true for me to be able
to you know have my own channel and
and talk to everybody about it so hey
thank you everybody for showing up
tonight really appreciate it we will we
will be back here next week that's how
you know i'm getting really tired
because i can't talk
we'll be back here next week
uh same time 11 30 pacific time um
and hopefully things get really really
good so
all right guys going to bed mr anderson
thank you and everybody else thank you
so much